In one particularly exciting cross test, the
Foundation set SCP-682, the infamous Hard
to Destroy Reptile, against SCP-204, a cloud
of deadly, all-consuming nanites bonded to
a small child for the purposes of protecting
them.
As SCP-682 naturally attacked the child, the
nanites sprung into action, forming the shape
of a huge warrior with an axe and shield.
The battle was intense, but amazingly, despite
taking tremendous damage itself, the SCP-204
warrior kicked the stuffing out of SCP-682.
As is expected of SCP-204, its nanites began
feeding on SCP-682’s immobilized body.
But, surprise surprise,
SCP-682 started regenerating
faster than the nanites could eat it.
It then began to attack SCP-204 once again.
The Foundation tranquilized both parties,
and hosed SCP-682 with hydrochloric acid,
before returning them both to their chambers.
All anomalies contained.
No children harmed.